the most egregious example of this kind
of institutional acceptance of lies
permeating the whole system came from a
headline in the hill last week headline
Phoenix protesters demand body cam
footage after police kill man in parked
car it's another one of these examples
of police brutality cops come up I'm
sure the man was black because that's
what that's what would make it
newsworthy right police come up there's
a man in the car and they probably woke
him up and they just started shooting
right is that what happened mm not quite
so you got to skip one two three four
five six seven paragraphs don't tell you
anything about what actually happened
they bury the lead by the eighth
paragraph we say the Phoenix Police
Department said in a statement Sunday
that an officer-involved shooting
occurred after a 911 caller said that a
man who tried to kill him last week had
returned with a knife and was
threatening to harm him the department
said that the caller pointed out the
alleged suspects location after they
arrived on the scene officers requested
additional backup before locating a man
sitting in a parked car in the driveway
of a house the department said officers
are said to have told the man that they
were investigating an aggravated assault
as the conversation continued officers
instructed the man to get out of the
vehicle at this point he refused instead
rolling up his window and armed himself
with a handgun and then the man began to
lift his weapon then one officer broke a
passenger window to attempt to distract
the man after see him point his weapon
at a fellow officer as that happened two
other officers fired into the vehicle
the department said and the man was
pronounced dead we actually don't we
don't have any info on who this man was
or or what happened before but this you
gotta wait eight paragraphs to find out
that this guy was had already tried to
kill somebody was armed with a gun
pointed the gun at the cops absolute
dishonesty
[Music]
[Music]
this video is sponsored by blink sale
the revolutionary invoicing software for
contractors and small businesses spend
less time billing and more time making
bank with blink sale get a free trial at
the link in the video description